hello everyone I was just browsing the
Internet as I usually do and I came
across the most interesting article on
chess calm it was written by Grand
Master Gregory sir / and the title of
the article was the strongest chess
player you've never heard of and I
thought to myself well I've heard of so
many chess players I I must have heard
of this one as well but to my surprise
I've never heard of this person the
person in question is a Czech German
master Rudolf beast Chuck and somewhere
around 1930s in 1935 he was rated number
79 in the world and as mr. sir per says
in his article according to the fidei
October reading list number 79 in the
world today was Alexander Milosevic and
I'm sure you'll agree in Grand Master
Alexander morosa which is a pretty
strong player and this game
Rudolph pitch Chuck is playing against
the Grandmaster Solomon floor a very
strong Czech Grandmaster and while he
was like a national hero in
Czechoslovakia in the 1930s in those
days you could buy the solo for
cigarettes the solo floor slippers the
solo for perfumes so the popular guy
definitely and somewhere around 1935
1936 he was rated number 2 in the world
he was even considered a contender for
the title so quite a matchup for mr.
pitch Chuck definitely in this game
Soloman floor has the white pieces and
he plays d4 we have a knight to f6
Knight to f3 and b6
a Knight B to D to c5 III Bishop to b6
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop to this long diagonal Bishop to
d3 there should to be seven solo castles
we have Bishop to e7 c4 Rudolph castles
and b3 Rudolph responds with d5 and here
there's a lot of tension going on in the
center but the position is pretty equal
neither of the players wants to be the
first one to capture Queen to c2 Knight
to c6 both players keep developing and
here probably mmm Flor should have added
some more protection to the
for more upon either with Bishop to b2
or maybe queen c3 or queen bee 2 would
also be ok but for some reason he played
a 3
he was probably worried about this
Knight jumping to before with an attack
on his a very strong Bishop and also
with a temple on the Queen so he played
a three and he allowed C captures on d4
and now you can't really capture with a
capture Sundy for you get D captures on
c4 and now you're losing this d4 pawn he
tried he tried another move which also
loses a pawn after C characters on d4 he
played C captors on d5 here mr. Rudolph
late Queen captures on d5 and after each
after sandy for Knight captures on d4
was played and well the problem is you
can't capture this night and before you
get Queen to g2 this is checkmate
so after night to d4 your queen is
attacked and there really isn't a good
Square for the Queen mister floor tried
Queen to be won this was well responded
to do with rook F to d8 and now the
threat is Knight captures an f3 would
check and then Queen picks up the bishop
on d3 night the e1 by mister floor
defending the bishop on d3 and also
guarding g2 Queen to h5 and here black
has so many threats that it's this is
well not possible to play for white a
move like h3 would definitely help white
but not for long so mister floor tried
Bishop to b2 trying to get rid of at
least one attacker but to this was
countered with Bishop to d6 riddle
doesn't care about the night as the
threat is Queen captures on h2 with an
instant checkmate
so g3 blocking the dark square Bishop
and we have Knight to g4 not the threat
again is Queen captures on h2 as the
knight is also attacking the square and
well in this position whatever white
plays even with the best defense it's
checkmate in 6 moves but mr. floor made
it a bit easier for mr. Rudolph he
played h4 and to this mr. Rudolph
responded with Queen captures and h4 and
after this move Salman floor resigned
the game if he were to capture
Quinn with G captures on h4 this is
followed by Bishop to h2 checkmate
but even with the best defense a white
can't really defend this it's checkmate
in five moves so yeah in this position
Salman floor resigned the game and a
great victory for rule of beat Chuck was
achieved so quite quite a spectacular
game actually for someone who will in
five years be rated number two in the
world and well the entire article is
pretty great as well I do recommend you
to to read it I will put a link to it in
the description below there are also
some very interesting games by mr.
Rudolph for example a game against young
Bobby Fischer from 1957 United States
Championship were Fischer luckily
escapes with a draw also there's a nice
game against Vasya Pearce and and a
couple of interesting games against some
weaker opponents one not weak but weaker
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I'm very interested if
any of you heard about a Rudolph pitcher
before this video or before the article
on chess calm I really like the
statement a Gregory sir per says that he
thinks it would be nice if the chest
community to remember from time to time
its unsung heroes I definitely agree
with him and well if I ever come across
a player I never heard of and he
produces such an amazing game I will
definitely show it on my channel so yeah
that's it I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kevin visnu FC and
an unknown person for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon